our homie
our homie
patrick mahomey
the home scrambling left holds it first
leg cut 10 5 touchdown and he's going to
sprint for the far pylon touchdown
freaking laser beams
patrick mahomes the defending nfl mvp
took his team to the afc championship
last year and but for the nfl's
inherently unfair overtime rules in the
postseason may have gone to the super
bowl will he get to the super bowl this
year we've got our picks we've got oh
and here's what's scary we just both
realized because in this last break yeah
i saw your picks yeah you saw my picks
and we came to the conclusion we spend
way too much time together
this is not good
the nfl we have a lot of the same
thoughts uh yeah i mean with that with
full disclosure here our afc playoff
picks we are uh have five of the same
teams we have one that differs right and
all four of the same division winners we
have them seated a little bit
differently both have the patriots as
the one seed the chiefs is the two seed
making them the champions of the afc
east and west respectively i've got the
jaguars as the third seed as the afc
south champions the steelers as the
fourth seed as the afc north champions
right sims has the jaguars fourth in the
steelers third so other than that it's
exactly the same i got the browns at
five the jets at six sims has the ravens
at five the brown's at six so yeah other
than the ravens and jets we agree on
everything it's amazing it is amazing
and i mean i mean first off i know you
and i
both like i don't i couldn't do the jets
as much as i like the jets or the
buffalo bills i know we talked about
them a lot as being like a fringe
playoff team which i think the ifc is
going to be extremely jumbled at the
bottom there where like i have the team
like i envisioned the browns being like
a nine and seven and maybe tied with two
uh two or three other teams in nine and
seven but they win the tiebreaker like
almost that type of scenario but i mean
no bills for us i know we talked highly
of them and we have high hopes for them
no cults huh no texans or you either
well look texans yeah i mean texans were
12 and 4 charges were 12 and four we
both left we both left them off so yeah
the colts texans and chargers are the
three that i'm most intrigued to just
know i want to know why you didn't
choose them ultimately well with the
texans i really do feel like last year
was
kind of an aberration they started
slowly they caught fire i just don't
think they're going to be able to
duplicate it this year and i think there
is disarray in that organization without
a general manager and and you know think
of
how confused all of us on the outside
were by the trades that happened this
weekend in the organization in the
locker room that's a lot to digest
quickly yeah and i don't know that you
recover from that quickly and go to new
orleans and beat the saints and maybe it
sets the tone
they've added some guys but they've lost
some guys and it's a lot of turnover for
division champion the charger phillip
rivers said it himself that they could
have been six and 10 or 16-0 last year
so many close games for the chargers and
i just think this year it's going to be
a different vibe for this team they're
not going to sneak up on anyone they're
going to be a team that gets circled in
ink on your schedule and you're going to
bring it against the chargers and we
know that's a real dynamic they're going
to be one of those teams that that other
teams are more dialed in when they
prepare to play them and it's just going
to be harder for them to get to get back
to 12 and 4. and i think if you lose a
few games early the guys who were there
last year they start getting a little
frustrated all this year is not going to
be as easy as last year and you think of
how you lost so so uh convincingly to
the patriots in the playoffs that kind
of i think that getting blown out in the
pa in the playoffs yeah that can have
more of a detrimental effect when you
reset to zero and zero than having a
close loss like the saints have had the
last two years right because it's like
what the hell we busted our butts for
all those weeks and then we go to
gillette stadium and get destroyed we
can't compete with the best teams in the
conference yeah they scare me too i mean
hey no melvin gordon you could say all
you want right melvin gordon's still a
special player i mean maybe he's asking
for too much money right now i'm not
going to disagree with that but melvin
gordon's a home run hitter so that
scares me that he's not on the roster
tyrell williams gone receiving core a
little less than was russell locum got
injuries derwin james not there out of
the fact they don't really have a home
field advantage and you talked about
they won so many close games last year i
do think the afc west will be better
this year i left them out too and then
you're not buying jacoby per set like i
want to see i need to believe i want to
see the way i am too i just couldn't put
it down on paper i'm rooting for him i
like the colts a lot of things there but
i just couldn't do it when it came time
to to flush it all out all right so wait
so let's go wild card yeah it definitely
gets more interesting as we work our way
let's work it let's work it out wild
card we both have the jaguars advancing
just over different teams i've got the
jaguars beating the jets you've got the
jaguars beating the ravens right we both
have steelers over browns that's the
last time the browns were in the
playoffs they played the steelers in
pittsburgh and lost the divisional round
is when it gets a little nutty because
you've got the jaguars beating the
patriots i do i've got the jaguars
beating the chiefs either one would be
an eye-opening holy crap outcome yes why
do we believe in the jaguars well i
believe in the jaguars one their defense
is phenomenal it's off the charts you
could argue it's the most talented
defense in all of football o-line some
injuries and little issues there but i
think really ultimately with a guy like
doug marone is the office aligned head
coach i like the guys they got on their
o line and i think when they're at full
strength they can be a dominant force
leonard fournette and a big year for his
career and the biggest thing being nick
foles i mean come on nick falls they
have receivers that i don't think are
household names but i think by the end
of the year you know i know you're privy
to them when we talk about dd westbrook
and some of the other guys they got
there where we're going to go oh wow
they've got some good players catching
the ball from nick foles but yeah i'm
high on the jaguars certainly and i
think the jaguars are the type of team a
little like the ravens who we saw that
give the patriots problems up in new
england the jaguars are built that way
too we're physical we know how we're
going to play the game we're not going
to mess up and they had them down 20 to
10 years you should have been up 17
right i'm playing the percentages this
year obviously i picked the patriots as
being the number one seed that this is
the first time in a decade they don't go
to the afc championship game i don't
necessarily feel comfortable about that
i'm just kind of going with a gut
feeling you know here's the thing it all
comes down to where the jaguar finish
i've got them at three yeah you've got
them at four so at three they beat the
chiefs at four they beat the patriots in
the divisional round if they can pull it
off and you know from my logic is and
big cat and i were talking about this on
friday the chiefs are going to be so
determined to get back to that game
against the patriots and finally get
past the patriots it's going to be like
the steelers a couple of years ago you
stubbed your toes losing the division
around just like the steelers you had
against the jaguar sure before you can
get back there you've got to punch your
ticket and i think the chiefs are going
to be very vulnerable and wouldn't it be
a great story nick foles going back to
one of the you know the guy who drafted
him andy reid and it was one of the
teams he played for that it didn't work
out and he we thought maybe he had a
chance there when when he landed in
kansas city and uh there's just a lot of
story lines that and and i try not to be
influenced by potential storylines or
make these picks but i do believe in the
jaguars now neither of us believe in
them enough to get to the super bowl
right both have them advancing to the
afc championship game i've got them
losing to the patriots you've got them
losing to the chief i do i just
ultimately
i think the jaguars probably need
another player or two they're going to
be in kansas city i just can't imagine
them winning that game and that type of
atmosphere and i just think the chief's
offense first off is going to be off the
charts good and their defense should be
improved i mean i like you know steve
spagnull i think that's an upgrade at
the defense coordinator position and i
like some of the additions they made as
far as players on their roster this off
season too so yeah i got the chiefs
going to the super bowl we'll release
the nfc uh after this i kind of got a
good story line as far as the super bowl
how it all played out i didn't intend to
do that
um but
i'm i'm looking forward to that but it's
amazing that chiefs jaguars is a week
one matchup that we're going to be
talking about here on friday right it's
going to be in jacksonville jaguars are
dealing with the whole hurricane issue
in florida right now so i do think that
changes the dynamic of the game a little
bit but i just think they're two teams
ultra talented on especially the jaguars
on the defensive side of the ball and
the chiefs offense of courses like the
jaguars on the offensive side of all
very special one last question for you
i've got two teams coming out of the afc
north you've got three yeah browns
steelers ravens yeah they play
all the teams of the afc west do they
play all the teams at the fc west they
just play one of the teams they play all
the teams at the nfc west yes and they
play all the teams of the afc east
meeting they all have to play the
patriots right i'm concerned that there
won't be three teams in that division
yeah that are good enough to box out the
cults the chargers right the bills of
the jets how much of that did you factor
into having enough faith
in those three teams to do win enough
games against that schedule to qualify
yeah that's where it got scary and
that's where i kind of come into my
logic because i really did i sat down
sunday morning and i looked at all
schedules and kind of just tried to play
it out in my brain a little bit and
where i got down into it is i just think
with with the afc north specifically
you're talking about with the three
teams them playing the nfc west i mean
some of these will reveal itself in the
nfc as far as what i think has going on
there but i think them
uh like the steel i mean the browns and
the and the uh ravens excuse me will win
tie breakers with teams like the jets
the bills the cults who again the colts
have are in a tough division as well and
their schedule is not necessarily easy
either but yeah i ultimately just looked
at it that way but like i said i think
that five six seven eight spot all could
have the same record this year the afc
is deep it's as deep as i can ever
remember it as far as good quarterback
plays and pretty damn good rosters it
was tough to tough to kind of flush this
out we'll do our nfc playoff picks later
in the show but one thing that i
experienced after saturday and as nutty
as saturday was with all those moves i
thought all right i'm glad i haven't put
my playoff picks out there i'm gonna go
back to the lab right but i went back i
didn't change a single thing wow i
didn't change one thing okay good for
you right yeah because i don't know like
uh i'm just glad i didn't have to deal
with the clowny thing beforehand that
might have made me rethink some certain
issues there either way but
i waited till sunday to wait to some
action get flushed out so i had a better
picture of what the teams were
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports